hey guys it's Kylie and Jordan air
jordan woods is ready to kiss and make
up with her former BFF Kylie Jenner you
have to find the happy medium of keeping
your private life private any personally
you know it's just
former pals had a major falling out in
February after Jordan was accused of
kissing Khloe Kardashian's now ex
Tristan Thompson and Kylie just
unfollowed Jordan on Instagram you could
do whatever when it affects like my
family me then that's when like it's a
problem in a new interview with
Cosmopolitan UK though Jordan says she's
got nothing but love for Kylie quote I
love her that's my homey and quote I
hope everything falls into place and
that we can all grow and build our
relationships with our family and God
and come back together one day and be
stronger and happier Jordan also says
she'd hate to be the reason for anyone's
pain I feel like you've moved on like
this is like you are not going backwards
what life moves on money doesn't stop
world doesn't stop and hopefully
everyone is just et was with Jordan last
month when she shared how she's putting
the past behind her and moving on so
what are you doing now what am i doing
justing busy thing positive moving
forward and more busy and that's true
she made a cameo on brownish and stars
in a new Rick Ross native video
[Music]